thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are currently off the
road what the [__] is that what's up
what
oh man look at that shine oh you guys
don't see this but Oh I thought that was
an American flag in the middle this is
woo I didn't know you that's those I
know you said they lit up I didn't
imagine it it actually you could select
what it says yeah you can't I don't
think it was that looking at you right
now Ryan
are you
that's how your eyes are I don't know I
don't know where you guys are anyway all
right that's uh Steve Green ladies and
gentlemen we got Joe bartnick and our
very special guest today we have Jessie
ma wow
[Applause]
thank you thank you so we're very lucky
to have her Jessie ma is a Powerhouse
writer she's um one of the people
responsible for the success of one of
the top if not the top dance uh program
online called easy you guys may have the
easy
um how do you write dance yeah five six
seven eight
movement it's like hieroglyphics it's
like the dance moves
yeah yeah same thing but how do you she
writes dance concert
no yeah
what a dance choreographer does are they
like composers they just write right do
you have to write slowly because dancers
aren't that smart oh yeah right because
they read slow so your letters have to
be written slow yeah yeah they can move
fast but they think no we don't know how
to read you so usually my job is useless
that's like yes usually Anthony's here
and then that makes more sense that
Steve's he's like the resident dance
culture suppressor suppressor yeah
I'm just losing here it's no this is the
believe all women song I don't think you
know this but you're a writer so we like
that yeah yeah but what do you write but
she's also a really good dancer too on
top of that we don't care okay okay got
it what does she write dance
choreography for reals like you might
dance Korea no I used to write about
dance lifestyle and dance tips and then
that turned into people all over the
world saying like oh these are great but
I want to learn how to dance and so
that's how we created all my dance
classes so was it like a dance blog yeah
yeah was it like I went to this battle
and then in Orion battled Anthony and
that sounds like a diary
fanfiction journalism for the culture or
the industry kind of yeah it started off
that way because it was like more about
being in the culture being in the
community and then it turned into dance
tips so helping people learn because
that does really well educational
content does really well that's cool
yeah and that the channel that she
worked on was was huge just in the
community and just as a YouTube channel
in general was like massive like all the
different ideas they had to make dance
fun and cool I know you guys don't give
a [__] about Dana don't say that I was
like I was listening bro dang I'm so
underground that I'm not a part oh
you're so underground so underground
yeah because for me I'm like
it's so new to me yeah so it's like you
telling me about like aborigine people
so I'm like whoa that's that's cool you
catch lizards and you break the head and
you suck on the blood I'm like wow
that's how I'm like taking it in yeah I
think for me it's sort of like you ever
ever think that something's been
overrepresented
yeah I think for this room probably
dance is that and he was supposed to be
a comedy channel but for some reason I
just love hiring dancers dancing all
[__] day bro we're in the dance world
now apparently I think we're in it
because we're we're we we sit with Ryan
we sit with Anthony you know and [__]
Steve Green these are Titans of the
dance I do cut it up I do cut it up on
occasion yeah I know Mike's song I know
Mike's song I have his phone number
so we're we're in Sonic trains that is
uh we're in the uh gym now we're in the
dance world now we're at Jason he thinks
he's cool because he knows Mike song I
have his number how do you guys know
each other how do you guys know each
other uh you know what's crazy is I
actually knew her when she was like a
kid yeah he doesn't remember though I
tell the story to everyone that doesn't
sound right
I also was a kid
kind of why did you say that yeah lead
with that isn't that weird we knew each
other when we were kids yeah 20.
[Laughter]
actually that's not weird she's still
older than my wife and I'm the same age
39.
how's your wife 29 no 30 no 30 yeah
he knows for sure powerful commentary
he's right there
I still want you to feel like a
pedophile I'll take the I'll take it I
feel like a pedophile we don't want you
to feel like
I appreciate that I felt okay you know
like especially with the cancel thing
going on I don't want you guys to be you
should spend more time talking about it
I didn't know it was high risk when I
was like 10 years old I had a crush on a
10 year old I don't want you to feel
like pedophile right I don't need that
support thanks okay
okay
in a very consensual friendship
non-sexual Type of Way well she said I
don't I don't remember and I kind of
don't
[Laughter]
I don't remember like the first first
time what was the what was your account
of the first first time I just took
class there and they were rehearsing at
Quest Learning Center and he was injured
so he was I was like waiting for my mom
to pick me up because I'm you know a
child
was like sitting on the side and he was
like hey
if I was like hey what's your name and
then not creepy no yeah but this is also
your business isn't it yeah yeah yeah
this is like your guys no Ryan is a
mentor he's a mentor he was like you're
the guy like you're the instructor
[Laughter]
you gotta move your shoulders no you're
[__] like oh okay what's what's your
name
that's not how it went down right
in the humble streets of Artesia
yeah it was
because because what was the quest
learning stuff all right so Quest
Learning Center is where uh Quest Crew
basically formed out of the that place
came first we named ourselves after the
facility as a way to like give back I
had no idea it's a tutoring place for
like kids to like learn math and stuff
yeah it's like a Kumon yeah it's like an
independent Kuma and there's a ballroom
at the bottom that doesn't get used as
much and so like we all subjects because
kumon's math right it's Quest like like
you guys do dance too and it's like math
uh it's like like the main math is the
main thing I think it's like stuff that
you need help on whatever subject you
have there's like a tour you can go
upstairs why is there a ballroom at the
bottom of a math class because it's a
Taiwanese owned uh place and they like
ballroom dancing I thought it was
revolutionary I thought it was so
revolutionary because I I thought like
all the Asian kids were like I want to
be a bad Asian boy but I gotta do my
homework first it was a little bit I
could do my bad Asian boy yeah yeah yeah
it was a little bit of that where like
kids who wanted to dance would use the
learning Center as like a fake like oh
I'm gonna go yeah learn math but then
they would come downstairs and like
practice dancing why is there a
Taiwanese restaurant in there too
because it's just it also had a cafe soy
milk yeah yeah there was a restaurant
and then after a while there was a like
a fake driving range like a digital golf
thing yeah and then that moved out did
you study there Jesse did you oh no this
one from the dance classes also you were
the bad Asian girl that was a bad guy
but they're just to dance but how did
you end up there how did you like even
um find out about it I like lived in the
area oh okay Yellow Pages I was like
yeah
what got you out of Dance what made you
go on yeah with this [__] what I still
did oh you still did I did I did okay
that wasn't one I read okay
I don't dance on like companies and
teams anymore got it yeah was it hard
convincing your parents to let you dance
because it feels like it's kind of like
untraditional right like it's easy to go
oh I need math help or whatever like but
signing up for dance was it weird was it
hard a little bit Yeah because my mom's
super traditional she's like really
supportive so she like enrolled me in
the hip-hop classes and stuff but it's
still like oh that's kind of it's kind
of like sexy you know it's like kind of
like in the sexy Realm of the dangerous
things that she doesn't understand yeah
yeah but your parents were they
Christian are they oh are they like
pretty like Korean oh okay did they give
you the talk
[Laughter]
religious parents are kind of weird like
that right like so did they talk to you
about like sex stuff no so they're just
like Shame Shame Shame let's not talk
about it though yeah yeah I feel like
that's the Catholic I didn't know what
how what sex was until like when I was
older
um later in high school
uh for the record your honor he said
what's your name and then and then what
was after also yeah what'd you say I'm
sure are you writing inside yeah what
happened what state was this in
California okay that helps no I remember
I was like
um and then I became a fan of him and
Quest Crew so I like followed all like
on MySpace and stuff oh but I didn't
re-meet him or them until ABDC like the
second time you know like when all the
Champions came together 2016. were you
on abdc2 no oh I was actually there with
um my old company to interview people
I see
so you're like like hey so like yo
you're gonna move out there
yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna move at my arms oh
you wonder what your legs are you gonna
move those things
I like to be a little different and not
move my legs
wow powerful commentary down here about
you guys in the studio
yeah
that's all it is
yeah and Anthony was there too at the
time yeah and she spends her she knows
Anthony too what do you think of Anthony
Lee yeah like what do you think about
loaded questions no seriously like like
you're honest genuine that's true what
would you say if he's not around yeah
like let's say he passed away oh and and
now there's no repercussions for what
you say yep and now you can say the real
[__] what how do you feel about him or
you just answer it the way I asked you
before it were just like what do you
think of Anthony yeah words you know
less pressure
really talented and really funny yeah I
think we think so too yeah no we do I
promise okay good yeah you don't think
so no no go ahead
I don't think so you guys don't think
he's talented we don't like him
straight up Steve doesn't like him so
you know genuinely no no no no well yeah
he's like he's really cool right yeah
yeah so like the joke when he's here is
that we make him not cool because it's
funny because it's like because
everywhere else he's like the man yeah
you know yeah so in this room the only
person that does it is we nag him so
hard oh really it's just me really
I honestly think he does he does I think
like he's obviously I think he like
because he's such a cool guy he's been
on TV he's like head of this big like
dance group company and he's like such a
big like mover in the space and you know
how like some bosses they like ball gags
anyway yeah yeah
I think that's him here yeah I think he
comes in he kind of opens himself
says some of the losers [__] that I'm
like don't don't reveal that he does
that on purpose so that we can [__]
[__]
like he wins everywhere else but he has
to come here and lose and then he tells
he doesn't like it but I know he does he
loves it but he licks his lips when he
says that so I don't know if it's true
and then he pulls us aside and he asked
us to stop him we just laugh yeah so we
love it it's good like there goes
Anthony being Anthony Ah that's so
Anthony Anthony's identity in here I
don't know why that is yeah but how do
you view them I think he's really cool
and really talented I think there's I
think maybe it's the coolness thing that
you guys break down in here but there's
sort of like a wall to really get to
know him for me something cool yeah
maybe you should talk about [__] so next
time yeah I know maybe he'll be like
more of a shallow pool
I found it to be more of a shallow pool
Anthony did you know him yes
you know all right so so after ABDC how
did you guys reconnect and become
friends
he just froze up here for the first time
I like introduced myself and everything
and then but it went I mean after that
there must been more interactions where
you're just like oh not only are you
part of the dance Community but now
we're friends yeah because you know it's
a really a really really big thing for
me I've never set a Google Calendar time
which is 15 for 18.
how quickly one's LinkedIn can be ruined
in this room 10 minutes oh my God 14
really the thing that was uh what meant
a lot and this was like a pretty big
deal to me is that she she was like
telling me look when I thought I was
meeting for the first time that she had
read my old MySpace really because I
used to like you're gonna make fun of me
I used to write I used to write a lot on
MySpace no you're an excellent writer
like every oh yeah you're a really good
writer bro you're a really good writer
where's this going right [__] no all the
IG captions are [__] insane okay yeah
so I used to write but I used to write a
lot of like heartfelt like [__] sappy
simpy yeah well just like no just like
you could like do bulletins and stuff
and then I used to I used to also have a
WordPress remember WordPress yeah yeah
have one of those and she and no one's
ever went up to me and went hey I read
your WordPress really but then she did
yeah yeah he wrote about it was like
like relationships and like
heartbreaking he's a good writer right
oh he's a really good writer really
really gone but yeah and then she like
uh like I've never heard anybody say
that and it like felt really cool to
like hear that yeah you still got some
of those phones really cool oh really
gone dude those were like I paid a lot
of money to have that deleted are those
captions is it effortless or it's just
like that's just how you like think I
really just think of the dumbest [__]
that I can find in my brain did it just
come to you like when you're spitting on
an age patient's car it just comes to
you you know like there's a guy doesn't
even the guy who has a disease and
you're like I shouldn't spin all over
his car
oh yeah it's an old story from what Ryan
used to do apparently no he's
no easy try had that that was like
really bad in all the students spit on
his car and then the following three
years later he died of AIDS
he's saying it literally did a quantum
physics to make it sound like it was you
once again we're just asking questions
so that's when that's your Muse I'm
ruined already anyways
yeah no that's no that doesn't that's
not where I go so so fast forward you
guys are friends and then now Jesse is
no longer a 15 year old but a dancing
beagle
legal owner of a dance teaching website
or app yeah yeah what is this so yeah
it's it's not it's like super I mean I
would be downplaying a ton if I just it
was a dance app but it's like the
leading dance lesson program like online
wow is that what Ken just was trying to
copy yeah they did it they didn't do a
good job no yeah they couldn't copy it
this seems like they couldn't crack it
they're trying to like
I was like what is this like Kia or
something what I was like because you
know it's like you know like oh there's
like Acura on Honda and you're like with
this one looks like that yeah yeah it's
a Kia Forte yeah what is this it gets
stolen a lot too yeah
so you have that and also
uh Ryan was telling us your crypto
you're into crypto too yeah she'd be
able to have amazing conversations with
that I'm like a fake fake crypto girly
though what's that mean like I like
pretend but I get the gist of it well
crypto's not real either oh that's true
yeah
do you hold any coins no not myself yeah
I am yeah what do you what do you got
that's why she's into nfts oh it was
mostly because my boyfriend what makes
you like isn't that kind of jumping
steps like you just go straight to nfts
from dance no no like we're skipping the
coins oh oh no it's because my boyfriend
he's in that scene he's super into NFL
yeah yeah or he was that I hope he's not
anymore see he was as smart I stayed
yeah are you totally oh I'm totally of
course I have like [__] 2 000
hennesseys what do you have everything
everything dragon eggs yeah I got
everything yeah
one of one one of every flavors Matrix
they came out so stupid Patriots was so
[__] dumb if Anthony was sitting in
it millions of dollars have been lost
and it's mostly on that side oh no yeah
well Anthony if he was sitting right
here
yeah we had a we had a great ride though
hell of a ride hell of a ride an
unforgettable rise and fall
I mean I could see a little bit of that
right now it would be so helpful so so I
mean we could do a facelift to this
office you guys would probably get a
maybe a 40 increase back because you
just lost 40 of your paychecks that'd be
nice can I ask a question yeah what
happened over there
what do you think
and there's just like a lot of men in
here and like a lot of testosterone so
maybe somebody just had like an aggro
moment Mark kicked it because the
neighbors were banging on the walls
because we were too loud that's really
what I know reversed yeah kicking
because they were making noise
self-destruction uh I think we were like
uh playing we're playing a really fun
game and it was like beer pong but on a
Roomba so imagine like you have to throw
the ball but the cups are moving so it's
like and then we're having a really good
old jolly time and then they started
banging and then they did it a couple
times and then I just like got angry
like really fast and I was like you shut
the [__] up and I went boom and I kicked
it oh [__]
that's what I was right kinda
and I think the other one's David So
demonstrating that you did that right
I don't remember that wall
before Joe reminded me about
me I thought I did that I think I did
the two of these you did the bottom ones
well do you want to put one in that I
can try yeah you're welcome to there's
like man in here man like that's a nice
coffee that's the first time we've heard
that though your bidet is like a sybian
or something it's like oh it's like
oscillates yeah sit on it for a little
bit oh there's Vortex if you hit Vortex
that's an enema is it for real is it
pleasurable I'll be right back yeah
oh can I tell you something that's kind
of don't be eating food right now
[Laughter]
every time I had diarrhea and my stomach
hurt really bad
um I would use the vortex option yeah
and it would fill up my guts like a
balloon oh it goes all the way up is
that what it's for
I think so it's called Vortex are you
supposed to use it to that degree Vortex
yeah well it might be our the days from
the other office but I remember
we had a it said the vortex it was an
orange button that [__] shoots through
that [__] no that should be penetrates
dude I should say are you sure on it you
know what it felt like imagine puckering
your lips and you don't want anything to
enter in your life and then the jet
stream is so strong that's a Super
Soaker shoots through I feel you need
malpractice insurance before you push
that button but it's still [__]
shooting you up until it's full and then
it all comes back how do you know when
you're full yeah oh you know
felt
like balloon animal yeah myself and it
inflated God and then it inflates it
when I'm ready I turn it off and I shoot
it all out oh you push you just push it
out of the [__] it's just pressure
dude it is one of the best uh you
recommend it you water boarded your
boyfriend in my butt exactly
uh would you recommend yes and also on
the flip side if you're if you're
constipated also a great okay good so
Vortex is pretty versatile it's yeah and
it's a perfect name for it did you think
we're gonna talk about this at the end
well it was nice to meet you
is a great guy